we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a voicemail about the horrifying
salman rushdie stabbing which we talked
about on yesterday's bonus show this
voicemail is from the eggman who we have
not heard from from for at least a few
weeks if not a month or two
hey dave i make a prediction that we
will never see salman rushdie in public
ever again either he is passed away or
he's gonna say they're gonna say he's
dead he's gonna fake his own death
that's it
we'll never see him again um i hope he's
okay but that's my prediction shalom
brother yeah um i uh so
since the eggman left that voicemail
the reports are that salman rushdie's
condition has improved which is great he
is now i believe if i understand the
last medical report expected to survive
he's 75 years old
and despite the fatwa officially
being
formally being rescinded
we all knew he was still at risk does a
public appearance and he gets stabbed
it would be perfectly logical
for salman rushdie to never show his
face in public again and it's sad that
that's the reality of the situation
but there is a contingent of people
determined determined to see rushdie
dead
and so i mean faking his own death or
simply never appearing in public again
honestly the situation is so crazy that
it all seems somewhat rational if he
were to do something like that for now
let's just continue hoping for his
recovery we have a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about the
complete and total backfire of the memit
oz crudite video which by the way i
covered months ago months and months ago
it's not a new video but it's gone viral
the biden administration has cancelled
almost four billion dollars in student
debt for more than 200 000 borrowers
we'll tell you who and why
and the nba the national basketball
association has decided it will not hold
games on election day in order to
encourage people to vote and of course
right wingers are furious even though
the nba is just saying just go vote
we're not telling you who to vote for
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get access by signing up at
joinpakman.com
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com pacman you
will get aura free for 14 days which you
can use to do things like see if your
passwords have been leaked the link is
down below